你知道股市裡面有一種100%會輸錢的單嗎而且這種單在下單的時候看起來很像100%會贏錢的單導致很多人會去下這種單前幾天我甚至看到了一筆一次下100口的長榮期貨換算就是台幣3000萬市值的單就是下這種100%會賠錢的單所以我們今天一定要好好跟大家講一講為什麼我們一定要很了解交易規則
還有股票期貨的結算價是怎麼樣結算的
那我們先讓時間回到2022年3月16號
那天是個星期三
風和日禮
那天是第三個星期三也就是
股票期貨的結算日
就是一個月第三個星期三
那我們來看看當天發生了什麼事情
當時的長榮期貨
這個最後都一直在144的位置
那
如果是掛單上的話
144跟144.5掛了超級多的買單跟賣單
為什麼會這樣呢
難道大家那麼確定會結算在144到144.5之間嗎
然後我們可以看下面的
這個成交明細
1點27分的時候有人空了100口的144長榮期貨
為什麼他會空100口的144呢
他就這麼有信心嗎
當天會結算在哪裡呢
我們看一下現貨
現貨這個時候
是在143跟143.5之間
而且很有可能就是在143
那我們最後知道最後確實是結算在143
也就是說呢
他是空
然後當天的收盤價
是基本上是143或143.5
那所以他空了100口的時候
他當然是覺得自己是會賺錢的單嘛
不可能有人去下
100%賠錢的單
但實際上這單是100%賠錢
144空
收盤價143
為什麼是一定賠錢
因為
股票期貨的結算價根本就不是等於收盤價
那
這邊
大家可以再心裡想想
你知道股票期貨的結算價是怎麼算的嗎
我們來看一下
這個
當天的長龍期貨是收在144.12
收盤價是143
也就是說他空了100口的144
他是賠錢的
那我們看一下
這個奇交所說的
股票期貨的
這個結算價是怎麼訂的
是
這個
收盤前60分鐘
的成交價的算數
算數平均數
也就是
這個12點半到
1點25分
之間每5秒跳動的一次的那個價錢
每一個這些數字全部加起來再除以
這個
數量
就是
算數平均
簡單算數平均到小數點
後第2位
好我們來這個按一下小算盤
為什麼是
這個660個數字
因為
有55個
55分鐘嘛
就是
12點半到1點25
55分鐘
每5秒跳一次價錢
所以
每1分鐘會有12個價錢
660個
價錢
然後呢
最後試戳的時候
會再多一個收盤價
所以是總共661個數字的算數平均
好
所以就是這樣
就是
這個
55乘以12
加1
這個大家懂吧
好
那也就是說呢
這個
期貨的結算價
就會是
現貨
從
這個
12點半到
1點25的算數平均
12點半在
這邊
也就是從這邊
這些
每5秒跳動一次數字的算數平均
當時已經12點25分過了
也就是說已經有
前面這邊到這邊的660個數字已經揭露出來了
那因為這些都是公開資訊所以有很多的App
都能夠
輕易的
即時算出
當時的
結算價
所以
市場才會這麼確定
會結算在144跟144.5之間
因為前
660個數字的平均就是144.12了
你可以說還有最後一個數字還沒有出來啊
會不會最後一個數字
把144.12這個平均給拉低了很多呢
那我們就來算一下
最多可以拉低多少
我們來重新叫出我們的小算盤
前660個數字的平均是144.12
那根據遊戲規則
最低的
收盤價是142.5
也就是跌停價
所以
我們就假設如果最後是
收在142.5
的收盤價的話
把總共扣了
1.62
但是這個1.62要
分給
這個
661個數字
所以我們把1.62除以661
也就是說
這個
最後就算是收在跌停
也只能夠讓
144.12減少
0.0024
也就是連小數點後
第二位都影響不到
所以
在當時
我們已經可以
百分之百的確定
這個結算價
是絕對不可能
低於144的
所以
他下的這個
100口的長榮期空單
是
100%會輸錢的單
而且還不只是他下喔
其實
我們可以看到
這個
最後幾分鐘是
一直不停有
144跟144.5在成交的
也就是說
這些人全部都在
瘋狂地成交
100%會
賠錢的單
真的是
超扯的
這個
就是
這個市場上
不了解交易規則
就一直去送錢的人
是真的超級多
在這邊
你看這邊是
成交量200多口
300多口
200多口
這個
100多口
這些全部都是在那邊成交
100%賠錢的單
你看144一直成交
因為很多人一直看到
現貨是143嘛
就一直有人在那邊成交
這真的不知道在幹嘛
那為什麼我說在
十幾分之後
這些就基本上
已經
都是100%賠錢的單
就是因為
後面剩下來的數字
實在太少了
而且後面剩下來的數字
基本上
都會在143附近
所以
就
已經沒有辦法把平均拉低到
144之下
來看一下
這個
這個是我的
訂閱者群組
當時這個是
1點15分的時候
然後我就
這個
這個是
我是手機截圖
當時
我已經出門了
早上賺了54萬
然後後來
尾盤我就掛了
滿滿的
次月跌停價
那這個其實我也不用看盤
反正
有人要一直送錢給我
那我後來就收了28口
我也不需要看
然後
所以我就用手機截圖
不是XQ截圖
然後問問大家
股票期貨結算價的規則是怎麼算的
為什麼那麼確定會結算在144到14.5
收盤前的
60分鐘算不平均
好很好
這個是跟訂閱者一些互動
然後
長榮期的次月當時我很早就掛了當天的跌停價
然後後來成交了28口
不過就是
就基本上
呃
我12點45後就是
全包了啦
如果有人願意給我100口
那我就收100口
就是有人要送錢給我
那這個也是一個策略
好我下一集來講
這個下一個影片來講
這個
當天同時我在長榮期次月的
這個操作好了
那
我們這個影片就到這邊吧
就最後講兩個
Take home message
第一個一定要很了解交易規則再去交易
不然的話你以為看起來144空收143
是賺錢結果是100%賠錢
第二個就是
做重大決定的時候
不要依據經驗法則來做決定
因為144跟143看起來
是一定賺錢的
但是
數學跟邏輯上是一定賠錢的
所以
第一個
了解遊戲規則再去交易
第二個
不要靠經驗做決定
要靠數學跟邏輯做決定
好
就這樣
我是馬克洋
謝謝大家